if anywhere symbolizes the importance of
reconciliation it is perhaps Hamburg
and in the ruins of Saint Nikolai Church
a memorial
where the king and German president laid
wreaths
it's the 80th anniversary of the Hamburg
bombings an eight-day air assault by the
Allies they targeted civilians and
killed 37
000.
the church Spire remains but only
because bombers used it as a marker it
is a great step and a strong signal I
think not only for us as an association
but also for for the Friendship for the
British German friendship
another moment of reflection at Hamburg
station stopping by the Kinder transport
Memorial
whole Hall is time the king and queen
consort are on a balcony will be the
coronation in may not welcoming weather
but hundreds turned up for a glimpse a
wave and a wet Walkabout
you hear a lot about the soft power of
the monarchy but there are hard messages
for the King to deliver during this
first date visit and what we've seen is
him selling Britain in effect on a
post-brexit PR push
Germany pulled out all the stops
[Music]
showcase friendship and renewed
relations
the late Queen made 121 State visits in
her Reign the king just finished his
first
Laura bundock Sky News Hamburg